- My name is Timothy Snyder
and I am here to welcome you
to the first in a series of lectures
which are organized within the framework
of a Franke seminar
here at Yale University.
The seminar is run by Professor
Jason Stanley and myself.
Its title is "Mass Incarceration
in the Soviet Union
and the United States."
We teach this as a regular Yale class
but we have the privilege and the pleasure
of being able to invite
people from whom we've learned
and people whom we admire
and people whose work
we're reading in the class
to give public lectures as well.
So I'll be introducing
and the students of the class are present
as well as others of you who have joined,
and thank you for that.
I'm gonna briefly
introduce Anne Applebaum.
She is known on the one side
as an author of a series
of extremely important
and lauded books on the
history of communism.
Most recently there is a history
of the famine in Ukraine, "Red Famine,"
which has brought the academic debate
and her own interpretation
into a highly accessible form.
I learned a lot from that book.
A few years ago there was a book about
the post-war takeovers,
actually a slightly revisionist account
of the post-war communist
takeovers in Eastern Europe
under the title "Iron Curtain."
And then towards the
beginning of the century,
in 2003 to 2004,
Anne wrote the book for
which she won a big prize
and which we read in the class
and which will be part
of her subject today.
It's called "Gulag: A History."
Clearly the most accessible
account of the Gulag
as well as providing
not just documentation
but themes and interpretation.
Anne is however also the author of a book
which in some sense
stays with me the post.
It's called "Between East and West."
And those of you who are
students and thinking about
how you're going to spend
the rest of your life,
the book is a kind of meditation
among many other things on that.
But in that book there is
this kind of foresight,
the book is a couple of
decades old now, more,
a kind of advanced warning
that there are things
between Poland and Russia,
that there are these countries,
this Belarus, this Ukraine,
and that someday they're gonna matter.
And there are a number of
other things in the book.
There's an interesting
reference to antisemitism
and the future of the Jewish
question in Eastern Europe.
So, Anne has written an awful lot
and from a number of different angles.
At a time when we're more
and more specialized,
Anne has done two things
which are unusual.
In writing about the communist world
she's also been a prominent
journalist about Europe
and the United States,
catching many of the
most important stories,
for example, of the Trump administration
right at the beginning.
And finally, she functions
not just in the United States
and not just in Europe,
although that's already a lot,
but from many different
international angles.
And in these ways she is something
which is rare these days,
all too rare,
which is an intellectual.
We're very glad to have Anne
introduce these lectures
and help get our course make a start.
Again, the subject for lecture is
"The Gulag: What We Now
Know and Why It Matters."
Anne, the floor is yours.
- Tim, thank you so much.
I so enjoy these long introductions.
(Tim laughs)
You also play so many
different roles as well,
as does Jason,
and I've had a chance to look
at the syllabus for your course
and it's a very interesting one.
I'm sorry I'm not taking it myself.
You're really combining a
lot of different things.
This evening I'm gonna
talk a lot about something
that for Americans in this context
may sound a little different or strange,
and it's not merely the
history of the Gulag
but the legacy and memory of the Gulag.
How does it continue
to matter or not matter
in Russian politics today.
And actually as I was thinking
about speaking this evening
I realized that I'm
talking to a generation
that might not know
that the Gulag for many decades
was a scarcely known,
hardly understood subject.
It was a vast system of camps
tucked far away in the Soviet Union.
Most Americans, most Europeans
knew very little about it.
Well, I'll speak about
that a little bit more.
And it only really came to
light in its full, you know,
we really began to understand what it was
and exactly how big it was
after Soviet archives
began to open in the 1990s.
And I was extremely
lucky to be able to work
in the Soviet Union in the 1990s,
that's a whole other subject
which if some of you
wanna discuss afterwards
I'm happy to talk about,
and my book was based on in some cases
the first plans and documents
that nobody had seen
or nobody had seen outside
of Russia for a long time.
And it was really in the
process of doing that,
in the process of going
through these documents,
that we began to understand
really what the Gulag was.
And so although the
legacy of Stalin's crimes
and the Gulag itself
will be the ultimate subject of my talk,
I will begin with a brief account
of what it is that we know now,
so what did we learn about the camps
since the breakup of the Soviet Union.
You know, what we know now that
we didn't know 30 years ago.
Obviously, in writing
my history of the Gulag
I didn't claim to have
discovered a brand new topic
that had never been touched on before.
Some of you will know
Solzhenitsyn's famous book
"The Gulag Archipelago"
which was a kind of oral
history of the camp system
that he published in the
West as a piece of samizdat,
meaning it was not published
ever in the Soviet Union
but it was published outside
of the USSR in the 1970s.
Although that was a document
based on his own experiences
and on the experiences of other people,
he didn't have archives,
actually he got the outline
of the story largely right.
He didn't have archives
but he did understand the basic outlines
of the Gulag's history
from its earliest incarnation
on the Solovetsky Islands in the White Sea
and how it spread across
the Far North from there
and then across the country.
But as a kind of asterisk,
in the years that I
spent researching my book
I conclude that archives
really do make a difference
in how we understand Soviet history,
and so I was able to work in
archives in Moscow, in Karelia.
I had access to documents from
archives in Saint Petersburg,
Perm, Vorkuta, Kolyma, Novosibirsk.
At one point I was handed
a part of the archive
of a small camp called
Kedrovy Shor in the Far North
and I was politely asked
if I wanted to buy it,
which I did and it's now
at the Hoover Institute.
What was available to me
was often quite ordinary.
It was the day-to-day archive
of the Gulag administration,
for example, with inspector
reports and financial accounts
and letters from the
camp directors to Moscow.
But it's true that when reading
these kinds of documents
the full extent of the system
and its importance to the Soviet economy
came sharply into focus.
So, for example,
these documents enabled
me to be far more precise
than it had ever been
possible in the past,
and so thanks to archives
we were able to learn
that there were at least
476 different camp systems
in the Soviet era,
each one made up of
hundreds or even thousands
of individual camps or (mumbles).
So the camps were,
there would be a central camp
and then there would be kind of (mumbles),
and this was particularly
true of the forestry camps.
So there would be one camp
and then there would
be small forestry camps
all up and down a highway usually.
And sometimes they were spread out
over thousands of square miles
of otherwise empty tundra.
We also know now that the vast
majority of people in them,
prisoners, were peasants and workers
and not the intellectuals who later wrote
the famous memoirs and books.
There were some of them too
but they were smaller in numbers.
We also know that with a few exceptions
the camps were not constructed explicitly
in order to kill people.
Stalin preferred to use firing squads
to conduct his mass executions.
He did kill people en
mass but not in camps.
Nevertheless, at times
they were very lethal.
So nearly 1/4 of the
Gulag's prisoners died
during the war years, for example,
between 1941 and 1945.
They were also very fluid.
So prisoners left because they
died, because they escaped,
because they had short sentences,
because they were being
released into the Red Army
or because they had been
promoted from prisoner to guard
which sometimes happened.
There were also frequent amnesties
for the old and for the ill,
for pregnant women and anyone
else who was no longer useful
to the forest labor system.
But these releases were
invariably followed
by new waves of arrests,
so it was a fluid
system, it wasn't static,
people's sentences could change,
either be much lengthened
or much shortened
even as they were there.
It wasn't a rule-of-law-based system.
People weren't sentenced by real courts,
they didn't have real sentences.
I mean, sometimes they had
these kind of kangaroo courts,
they were called troikas.
But the camp population actually changed
according to the Soviet
Union's labor needs.
But as a result of this, between 1929,
which is when they first
became a mass phenomenon,
and 1953 which is the
year of Stalin's death,
some 18 million people
passed through them.
In addition, a further six
or seven million people
were deported not to camps
but to exile villages.
And so in total that means
that the number of people
with some experience of
incarceration or imprisonment
in Stalin's Soviet Union
could have run as high as 25 million,
which at that time was
about 15% of the population.
We also know where these
camps were, namely everywhere.
And so although some of
you who know Solzhenitsyn
and who know Soviet literature
might be familiar with the image
of the prisoner in the snowstorm
digging coal with a pickax,
there were camps in central Moscow
where prisoners built apartment blocks
or designed airplanes,
there were camps in Krasnoyarsk
where prisoners ran nuclear power plants,
there were fishing camps
on the Pacific Coast.
I once had the chance to look
at the Gulag photo albums,
these were albums put together
by the Gulag administrators,
and they included pictures of prisoners
with their camels in Central Asia.
And so from Akhtubinsk to Yakutsk
there was not really a
single major population
in the Soviet Union
that did not have its
own local camp or camps
and not a single industry
that did not employ prisoners.
So over the years prisoners
built roads and railroads,
power plants and chemical factories,
manufactured weapons, furniture,
even children's toys.
In the Soviet Union of the 1940s,
which was in fact the decade
that the camps reached their zenith,
it would have been very
difficult in many places
to go about your daily business
and not run into prisoners,
and it is therefore no
longer possible to argue
as some once did
that the camps were known to only
a small proportion of the population.
We also understand better
the chronology of the camps.
So we've long known that Lenin
built the first ones in 1918,
so at the time of the
Bolshevik Revolution,
so the camps absolutely date
back to the very beginning.
And originally they were kind
of ad hoc emergency measure
to contain enemies of the people,
which was a designation that meant
enemies of the revolution,
people we don't like,
it could be applied to almost anybody.
Again, this is not a system
that has rule of law.
And of course they were designed
to prevent counterrevolution.
They also were sometimes meant
to reeducate the bourgeoisie,
the opponents of the Bolsheviks.
We also have long known that
Stalin and his successors,
I mean, excuse me, that Lenin
and his immediate successors
expanded the camps to
the Solovetsky Islands.
It's a group of islands in the
Far North in the White Sea,
in the northern part of
Russia, in the 1920s.
And that original expansion was, again,
initially for the political
opponents of the Bolsheviks
who were often other socialists,
so social democrats or
social revolutionaries,
people who the Bolsheviks
found to be ideologically threatening,
and they were initially put
in this group of camps on a,
there was a monastery on
the islands in the north,
although that was initially
a relatively small operation.
But the archives also help us understand
why Stalin chose to expand them in 1929.
So in that year Stalin
launched the five-year plan.
This was an extraordinarily
costly attempt,
costly in both human lives
and natural resources,
to force a 20% annual increase
in the Soviet Union's industrial output
and to collect agriculture.
This was Stalin's attempt to
push the Soviet Union faster,
to modernize faster.
And one of the side effects of the plan
was millions of arrests
as peasants were forced off their land,
maybe you'll discuss
that later in the course,
and imprisoned if they refused.
It also led to an enormous labor shortage.
Suddenly, the Soviet Union found itself
in need of coal, gas, and minerals,
most of which could be found only
in the Far North of the country.
Following a series of discussions
which used almost exclusively
economic language.
Again, I had the chance to read
as the leaders of the Soviet Union,
this is after Lenin's death,
this is now when Stalin is a leader,
as they were discussing
how to expand the camps.
There are records of the conversations
that the Politburo had at that time,
the leadership of the Soviet Union,
and what's very striking about them
is that almost exclusively
economic language is being used.
So the decision is taken
that we need the prisoners
to extract the minerals.
And of course to the secret policemen
who were charged with carrying out
the construction of the camps
this made a great deal of sense.
So here is how Alexei Loginov,
who's the former deputy
commander of the Norilsk camps,
these were north of the Arctic Circle,
this is how he justified
the use of prisoner labor
in a 1992 interview, so many years later.
He said, "If we had sent civilians,
"we would first have had to build houses
"for them to live in.
"And how could civilians live there?
"With prisoners it is easy.
"All you need is a barrack,
a stove with a chimney,
"and they survive."
So prisoners in Gulag
documents are often referred to
as (speaks in foreign
language), contingence.
From the point of view
of the Soviet leadership
and of camp commanders,
they were an ingredient of production.
They were like lumps of
coal or bars of steel.
Enemies of the people didn't
need to live like civilians
in normal houses.
They could be put in barracks,
it didn't really matter
what happened to them,
if there wasn't quite enough food for them
it wasn't a tragedy,
they were both cheap and expendable.
They weren't human, they were enemies,
they could be used in this way
which was very useful
for a country that wanted
to modernize very fast.
That isn't to say that the camps,
in addition to their economic function,
which as I say that's how
they were always described,
were not also intended to terrorize
and subjugate the population.
Certainly, prison in camp regimes
that were dictated in
minute detail by Moscow
were very openly designed to humiliate
and dehumanize prisoners.
So the prisoners' belts
and buttons and garters
and items made of plastic
were taken away from them.
Again, they were described as enemies.
They were forbidden to
use the word comrades
which was only for people, you know,
for fully paid-up citizens of the state.
And, again, those kinds
of measures contributed
to their dehumanization
in the eyes of guards and bureaucrats
who therefore found it that much easier
not to treat them as fellow citizens
or even as fellow human beings.
And in fact this turned out to be
quite a powerful ideological combination.
So the disregarding of
the humanity of prisoners,
on the one hand,
combined with the overwhelming
need to fulfill the plan.
And nowhere is this clearer
than in the camp inspection reports.
These were submitted periodically
by local prosecutors,
kept neatly on file in Moscow,
which is where I found them.
When I first began to read them
I was actually quite shocked at first
both by their frankness
and the peculiar kind
of outrage they express.
So, for example, describing
conditions in Vorkutlag,
this was a railroad
construction camp in Tatarstan,
in July 1942,
one inspector complained that
"the whole population of the
camp, including free workers,
"lives off flour.
"The only meal for
prisoners is so-called bread
"baked with flour and water
without meats or fats."
And as a result, the
inspector went on indignantly,
there was a high rate of
illness, particularly scurvy,
and not surprisingly the
camp was failing to meet
its production norms.
So this outrage, you're
mistreating these prisoners,
this ceased to seem surprising
after I had read several
dozens similar reports,
each one of which used more or less
the same sort of language
and each of which ended with more or less
the same ritual conclusion.
You know, conditions need to be improved
so that the prisoners will work harder
and so that the production
norms will be met.
But very little was actually done.
So while it might have been expected
that living conditions in the Gulag
were poor during the war,
as they were all across the Soviet Union,
a nationwide inspection, for example,
of 23 large camps in 1948
still concluded among other things
that 75% of the prisoners
in Norillag, in Norilsk,
had no warm boots,
that the number of prisoners
unfit for hard labor in Karelia,
meaning they were too weak,
had recently tripled,
that death rates were
still, quote unquote,
"too high" in 1/2 a dozen camps,
meaning that it's too high to allow
for efficient production.
Without question the
expansion of the camps
distorted the Soviet economy.
With so much cheap labor available
the Soviet economy took far
longer than it should have done
to become mechanized.
This is of course the irony of
Stalin's modernization push.
Problems were solved by
calling for more workers.
Famously, the White Sea Canal,
one of the early Gulag projects,
was built with pickaxes
even at a time when
more sophisticated
equipment was available.
With so many poorly trained
people working under coercion,
the construction was not of
the highest quality either.
By one account, labor or
productivity among the free workers
in the forestry industry
was nearly three times that of prisoners
working in the forestry camps.
But the camps also distorted the way
that people in the lands
of the former Soviet Union
thought about economics.
This is a little diversion
but it's an interesting point
which I can illustrate
by describing a trip
that I took a few years ago,
quite a few years ago now,
to the city of Vorkuta
on the Arctic Circle.
Vorkuta's history begins in 1931
which is when a group of colonists
first arrived in the region by boat
up the northern waterways.
Although even the czars had
known about the region's
enormous coal reserves,
no one had managed to work out
precisely how to get the
coal out of the ground
given the real horror of life
in a place where
temperatures regularly drop
to minus 30 or minus 40 in the winter,
where the sun doesn't shine
for six months of the year,
and where in the summer,
which is when I was there,
the mosquitoes travel in
these enormous dark clouds.
But Stalin found a way
by making use of another
sort of vast reserve.
Vorkuta's original 23
settlers were prisoners
and the leaders of that
founding expedition
were secret policemen,
and over the subsequent 2 1/2 decades
a million more prisoners
passed through Vorkuta,
one of the two or three most
notorious hubs of the Gulag.
With the help of prisoners,
the Soviet authorities built shops
and swimming pools and schools.
But the cost of heating
these shoddy Soviet apartment blocks
for 11 months of the year
turned out to be astronomical,
far more than the value
of the coal itself.
The city's infrastructure,
which was built on this
constantly shifting permafrost,
required huge efforts to maintain.
Instead, miners could have flow in
on two or three-week shifts
like they do in Alaska or in Canada.
There was no need to
build this city there.
Nevertheless, the city
of Vorkuta kept going
throughout the 1970s and 1980s and 1990s
and many thousands of people
still live there today.
Truth, of course, is that
Vorkuta is unnecessary,
the city is unnecessary.
Why build kindergartens and
an university in the tundra?
Why build a puppet theater?
Vorkuta had three.
But in Vorkuta it was really
difficult to ask such questions
even after the USSR collapsed,
and I have a particularly strong memory
of a day that I spent there
with a retired geologist.
She was named Genia.
And together we walked around the city,
we went to the prisoners cemeteries,
we went around the ruins of
the Geological Institute,
a once solid structure
complete with a column,
a Stalinist portico and a
red star on the pediment.
Genia's Polish parents had been
arrested and deported there
in the 1940s
and she knew that story, of course,
and she knew the city's history very well.
And nevertheless she railed against
the people she called
the greedy bureaucrats
who had shut down the institute
and who were shutting down
those parts of the city
that simply weren't economic to keep up.
If your whole life has been
associated with a place,
it is really hard to admit that that place
need never have existed
or that it won't exist in the future.
Even if that place is widely famed
for atrocity and stupidity,
even if it's notoriously unpleasant,
it is really hard to admit
that it ought not to
have been built at all.
But if Genia who was
the daughter of victims
was unable to understand
the strange economics
situation of her city
and the role it played in history,
then who can?
And this question brings me
to the next part of this talk
in which I'd like to ask why the Gulag,
about which historians now know so much,
since my books has been written
there have been many others,
there's a fantastic amount of research
that is widely available,
and whose economic impact
we understand so much better
and whose psychological
impact we understand as well,
why is it so seldom debated and discussed
by modern Russians?
And in this I'll talk about
the Gulag in a larger sense,
why is the Gulag rarely discussed?
Why are Stalin's crimes rarely discussed?
Why is it so disappeared from
the modern Russian debate?
I mean, one of the things
that always strikes
contemporary visitors to Russia
is the lack of monuments
to Stalin's victims.
So, there are a few scattered memorials
but there's really no national monument
or place of mourning.
And actually the absence of monuments
is an accurate reflection of
the absence of public debate.
I should say this was not always the case.
So there were wide-ranging
discussion of Soviet repression
in the 1980s.
This is the very end of the Soviet period
during the reign of Mikhail Gorbachev.
And actually these discussions played
an important maybe key,
maybe absolutely central role
in delegitimizing the Soviet regime.
So once, as I mentioned at
the beginning of this lecture,
all these subjects were kept,
they were heavily secret,
they were not talked about
while the Soviet Union existed,
and in this outpour of glasnost,
this moment when suddenly
all kinds of things
were possible to talk about in the 1980s,
one of the first things that happened is
people began to talk about the camp system
and the crimes of the camp system,
the crimes of the Stalin era.
And people then began to ask
if this system that we're still part of
created all these horrors,
why should we support it anymore?
And as I said these were
really important discussions
at the time,
but this debate, the
bitter debate at the time
about justice for the victims
is now completely over
and it really left no political
institutions in its wake.
And so although there
was much talk about it
at the end of the 1980s,
the Russian government never did examine
or try the perpetrators
of torture or mass murder,
even those who were still
alive or identifiable.
There were no truth commissions,
there was no natural debate
of the kind implemented in South Africa
which might have allowed
victims to tell their stories
in an official public
sphere, in a public venue.
There was certainly no
compensation for victims.
At some level the reasons for
this are not hard to fathom.
Even by 1990-91, the Stalinist
era had been long passed.
The last Stalinist camps closed
after Stalin died in the 1950s.
There had been a smaller camp system
just for political prisoners
that lasted right up to
the end of the Soviet Union
and has now been revived under Putin.
But the era of mass incarceration
had been over for a long time
and a great deal had
happened since it had ended.
Post-Soviet Russia was not the
same as post-Soviet Germany
where memories of the worst atrocities
were still very much
present in people's minds.
The memories of the camps
is also confuse in Russia
by the presence of so
many other atrocities,
the other things to remember.
You know, the war, the
famines, collectivization,
the mass murder.
Why should camp survivors get
some kind of privileged
status or treatment?
I think in a way the problem
is made even more confusing
by the link that was made
in some people's minds
between that discussion of the past
that took place in the
1980s, which I've mentioned,
and the collapse of the
economy in the 1990s.
So people would say,
people used to say this to me in Russia,
"What was the point of
talking about all of that?
"It didn't get us anywhere."
There's also a kind of question of pride.
Like Genia, many people experienced
the collapse of the Soviet Union
as a kind of personal blow.
It altered their identity,
their world made no
sense after it was gone.
Who were they, what was their nationality?
But also perhaps the old system
was bad they might have felt
but at least we were
powerful and important,
and now that we are not powerful
we really don't wanna
hear that it was bad.
Still, I think that the
most important explanation
for the lack of debate,
and here I'm gonna be interested,
I would be interested to hear
how you're gonna compare this
to the American experience,
the most important explanation
for the lack of debate
is not really the fears and
anxieties of ordinary Russians
but it was really to do with the nature
of the country's new ruling class
who remain the current ruling class.
So, Vladimir Putin who's
the president of Russia
is a former KGB officer
who has described himself
using the word Chekist,
which is a word that Lenin
used for the political police.
Famously, Putin has also described
the breakup of the Soviet Union
as the greatest geopolitical catastrophe
of the 20th century,
presumably meaning greater
than World Wars I or II.
So under his watch Soviet
flags have returned
to anniversary parades,
the Soviet national
anthem has been revived,
Soviet symbolism of all
kinds has been brought back.
And the reason for this is quite clear.
Putin is trying to create
an alternate version
of post-Soviet history,
one which supports his
claims to rule the country.
So, by his version of the past,
1991, which is the year
the Soviet Union broke up,
was not a moment of liberation.
It was the beginning of economic collapse.
The hardships and
depravations of the 1990s
were not the result of
decades of communist neglect
and widespread theft
but of Western-style democracy.
Communism was stable and safe,
post-communism was a disaster.
The Soviet Union was great.
Russia, at least until Putin took over,
was a failure.
The more people believe
that version of history,
the less likely they are to want a system
that is more genuinely democratic
and which offers people real
opportunities to advance
which isn't a top-down
controlled kleptocracy.
The more nostalgia,
but on the contrary, the more
nostalgia for the Soviet era,
the more secure Putin and
his kind of ex-KGB clique
is likely to be.
So, in other words, the
failure to discuss the past
or dwell on the past or repent the past
or focus on the past
is a part of this redirecting of history
towards the political needs
of the present rulers.
But it has also had consequences
for the formation of
Russia's civil society
and for the development of rule of law.
It helps explain, for example,
why Russians are not as
bothered as they should be
by certain kinds of censorship
or by the new tactic of naming
any independent journalist
as enemies of the state.
They're now called foreign
agents but it's the same idea.
Why when the FSB,
which is the modern
incarnation of the KGB,
when they are given free rein
to open mail or tap telephones
or enter private residences
without a court order
why there's not more objection to this.
The sense that there needed to be a break
with the old system,
that the lack of rule of law
demands a profound change
never really happened.
I think there's a kind of
deeper significance too.
To put it bluntly,
if the scoundrels of the old
regime all went unpunished,
there was no justice in the new system,
and so good didn't triumph after 1991.
And this may sound a
little bit apocalyptic
but it's not politically irrelevant.
So, after 1991, when the
Soviet Union broke up,
the secret policemen, the
leaders of the old system,
they kept their apartments,
their country houses,
their large pensions,
and their victims, the former prisoners,
remained poor and marginal.
And so to most Russians it now seems
as if the more you
collaborated in the past,
the wiser you were.
If you were a winner
then, you're a winner now.
And by analogy, the more you cheat and lie
and stay within the system in the present,
the wiser you are now too.
That there's no benefit from justice.
You don't gain anything
from seeking redress for past crimes.
Personally, what bothers me the most
about Russia's lack of interest
in this part of its past
is the way it's deprived young
people some of their heroes.
The names of those who
secretly opposed Stalin
ought to be as widely known in Russia
as they are in Germany, for example,
as the names of the participants
in the plot to kill Hitler.
The incredibly rich body of
Russian survivors literature
which I used to write book,
these are tales of people
whose humanity triumphed
over horrifying conditions,
and there's amazing stories
of friendship and bravery.
These should be better
read and better known
and more frequently quoted.
If school children knew these heroes
and their stories better
they would find something to be proud of
in Russia's Soviet past
aside from imperial and military triumphs.
This, after all, is the
country that invented
the modern human rights movement,
and yet I don't think most
Russians think of that
or remember it.
Instead, that part of Russia's
past remains very closed,
almost like a kind of
unopened Pandora's box.
It lies in wait for the next generation.
But do we, in the US or in Europe,
do we remember the Soviet past
which is a part of Soviet history,
it's a part of world history,
do we remember it any better?
One of the reasons I wrote my Gulag book,
this was one of my
inspirations in the late 1990s,
was because I really
encountered this subject myself
only while living in Eastern Europe.
I remember the first person I met
who had been a Gulag prisoner
was in Vilnius, in Lithuania.
It was a man who explained to me
how you could pack lots of
people into the back of a truck
because he remembered how it had been done
in the 1940s when he was
deported along with his family.
But this subject wasn't
taught in my school,
even though I studied
Russian history at Yale.
It wasn't subject of great interest,
it wasn't a major part of any curriculum,
we didn't have a course like the one
Professors Snyder and
Stanley are teaching today.
The Gulag when I was growing up
was not really part of
popular culture either
the way that Nazi camps were.
You have an image in your mind
of what a Nazi camp looks like
but not of a Gulag camp.
But it wasn't really part
of standard histories
of the 20th century,
it just wasn't a subject
that you encountered.
And I spent a lot of time
thinking about why that was as well,
and I felt once again it
was possible to explain
this absence of popular feeling
about the tragedy of European communism.
Also there were some logical explanations.
Again, the passage of time was part of it.
Communist regimes also
grew less reprehensible
as time went on.
Nobody was very afraid
of General Jaruzelski
who was the last communist
dictator of Poland.
Nobody was frightened of
the final Soviet leaders,
even Brezhnev and Andropov,
as much as they were frightened of Stalin,
although both were responsible
for a great deal of destruction.
But besides, as I've said,
the archives were closed.
Access to campsites was forbidden.
No television cameras ever
filmed the Soviet camps
or their victims
as they had done in Germany
at the end of the Second World War.
And no images in turn meant
that the subject in our
image-driven culture
didn't really exist either.
To this day it's very difficult
to make documentaries about the Gulag
because there just aren't photographs,
there aren't pictures.
But ideology also shaped the
way in which we understood
Soviet and East European history as well
for as long as that system existed.
And this is an interesting
point that again you'll find
might have further echoes in
the course that you're doing.
In Europe and the US
you can actually trace
the ups and downs of
knowledge of the Soviet Union.
So, at different times people
knew more or less about it,
at different times the
story figured more or less
in the popular press.
In other words, the politics of the West,
so the politics of Europe,
the politics of the United States,
actually affected the way we
understood Soviet politics.
So, for example,
in the 1920s a great deal was
known in Western capitals,
in Berlin, in London, in Washington,
about the bloodiness
of Lenin's revolution.
And that was because the first victims,
as I mentioned already,
of the revolution were socialists.
And Western socialists.
So, again, in all the important capitals
knew that their brethren, their comrades,
had been jailed by the Bolsheviks,
and the first people to really
protest loudly and strongly
against the crimes being
committed by the revolution
were on the left.
However, in the 1930s,
as Americans and West Europeans
became more interested
in learning how socialism
could be applied at home,
this was a time of
economic crisis in the West
and people were looking
for other solutions,
the tone changes
and then American and European
writers go off to the USSR
and they try to use to learn lessons
that could be brought back.
Famously, some of what later became
Franklin Roosevelt's kitchen cabinet
went to the Soviet Union
to see if there was
something they could learn.
The New York Times at that time
employed a correspondent, Walter Duranty,
who lauded the five-year plan
and argued against a lot of evidence
that it was a massive success.
He also argued that
collectivization was not a disaster
and he covered up the
stories of the famine,
specially in Ukraine,
even though he knew they were true,
and he won a Pulitzer Prize for doing so
because this is what
people wanted to hear.
There was a moment when people
didn't wanna hear anymore
about why the revolution was bad,
they wanted to hear what was succeeding,
or what they thought was succeeding.
Throughout the 1930s and 40s, a part of,
I would say it's not
even the Western left,
I would say mainstream Western politicians
struggled to explain and
sometimes excuse the camps,
because the stories would filter through,
and the terror that created them
precisely because they wanted to try
some aspects of the
Soviet experiment at home.
So our politics shaped our understanding
of the Soviet Union.
And this became even more complicated
during the Second World War
when Stalin was our ally.
So in 1944 the American
Vice President Henry Wallace
actually went to Kolyma,
which is one of the most notorious camps,
during a trip across the USSR,
which he said reminded
him of the Wild West.
There's a famous quote where he says,
"Soviet Asia reminds me
so much of my homeland."
According to a report
that the boss of Kolyma
later wrote for Beria
who was then the head of
the Soviet Secret Services,
Wallace did ask to see prisoners,
so he knew where he was,
he knew he was seeing a
site of mass incarceration,
but he was kept away from them.
He was not alone in not wanting
to know this piece of truth,
this aspect of the Soviet system.
Obviously at that moment
Roosevelt and Churchill
were meeting regularly with Stalin.
They had their photographs taken with him,
they saw him as an ally in
their war against Hitler,
and so they were simply not interested
in bringing up this subject.
All of that is part of what contributed
to our firm conviction
that the Second World War
was a holy just war.
And even today very few people
want that conviction shaken.
So we remember D-Day,
we remember the liberation of
the Nazi concentration camps,
we remember children
welcoming American GIs
with cheers on the streets,
and we don't remember that
the camps of Stalin, our ally,
expanded into Eastern Europe,
this is the topic of my
book that Tim mentioned,
on the expansion of the Soviet system
into Poland and
Czechoslovakia and Hungary.
We don't remember that
those camps expanded
just as the camps of Hitler,
our enemy, were liberated.
So nobody wants to think that
we defeated one mass murderer
with the help of another.
During the Cold War, it's true,
our awareness of Soviet
atrocities went up again.
Again, this reflected American politics
and American political needs
rather than anything that
was happening in the USSR.
In the 1960s they receded again.
Even in the 1980s when I was at Yale
there were still American academics
who would describe the advantages
of East German healthcare
or Polish peace initiatives.
They would try to push the
values of these systems.
And at the time when
I was an undergraduate
in the academic world
Soviet historians who
wrote about the camps
were kind of generally
divided into two groups.
Those who wrote about
the camps as criminal
and they were called kind of right wing,
and those who downplayed them
if not because they
were actually pro-Soviet
but because they were
opposed to America's role
in the Cold War
or maybe Ronald Reagan.
In other words,
one's attitude towards the
Soviet Union and its camps
was very often shaped
by one's own politics,
and I'm saying this neutrally.
I'm not saying that one
side was bad or good.
That your view of the USSR
was shaped by your view of
America and the Cold War.
And really right up until
the very end of the Cold War
our views of the Soviet Union
and its repressive system
always had more to do
with Americans politics
and American ideological struggles
than they did with the
Soviet Union itself.
I mean, it's a lesson that we see things
through the lens of our own time
and we found it difficult
to talk about this subject
in a neutral way
while the Soviet Union still existed.
I should add that
there are people who maintain
that this is still true.
I actually don't think so.
I think it's now possible,
as Tim Snyder does, as many others do,
to write about Soviet history in a way
that doesn't reflect your views
about America or the Cold War or Reagan.
Because the Soviet Union
doesn't exist anymore
and because it's a part of history
you can write about it in a neutral way,
and one of the reasons there's so much
good Soviet scholarship in the last years
is because the ideology is
gone, the struggle is gone,
and now we can begin to see
the system for what it was.
So, as I said,
since the collapse of
the Soviet Union in 1991,
much has changed.
World War II really now
definitively belongs
to a previous generation.
The Cold War is over.
The alliances and the
international fault lines
that it produced
have shifted for good.
The Western left and the Western right,
if you can even use those terms anymore,
they now compete over different issues.
And so finally it's become possible
to stop looking at the
history of the Soviet Union
through the narrow lens
of Western politics.
And I'll finish by saying
that it's not only possible,
I believe it's necessary,
I'm really glad that there's
another generation of students
who will investigate this story,
who will interest themselves in it.
Because after all, in an important sense,
the Gulag is part of our history too.
Why did we fight the Cold War after all?
Was it because some crazy
right wing politicians
in cahoots with the military
industrial complex and the CIA
because they invented the whole thing
and they forced two
generations of Americans
to go along with it?
Or was there something
more important happening?
I'm not sure we still remember
what it was that mobilized
us, what kept us together,
what held the civilization of
the West together for so long
and what the useful part of that story was
and what we achieved by doing that.
But of course it's also the case
that the history of the Gulag
belongs in a much broader sense
to the history of mankind.
Every one of the 20th century's
mass tragedies was unique.
The Gulag, the Holocaust,
the Armenian massacre,
the Nanjing massacre,
the Cultural Revolution,
the Cambodian Revolution,
the Bosnian Wars.
Every one of these events had different
historical and philosophical origins.
They all arose in circumstances
that will never be repeated.
But it is our ability
to debase and destroy
and once again dehumanize our fellow men,
this is something that
can and will be repeated
again and again.
It's our ability to
transform our neighbors
or our fellow citizens into enemies.
Our reinvention of our victims
as lower or lesser or evil beings
worthy only of incarceration or expulsion
or forced labor or sometimes death.
These things are repeated again and again.
And the more that we
are able to understand
how different societies
have accomplished this,
how they have transformed their neighbors
and fellow citizens into objects,
the more we know of the
specific circumstances
of each episode of mass murder
or of mass dehumanization,
the more that we will understand
the nature of, you know,
human nature itself.
I wrote my book about the Gulag
not so that it will not happen again,
which is how the cliche goes.
Because it will happen again
and it has happened again.
And I think we need to know why
and each story, each memoir,
each document is a piece of the puzzle.
If we don't have them,
we will wake up one day and realize
that we don't know who we are.
So, thank you very much.
I look forward to your questions.
It's been a pleasure speaking to Yale
and New Haven residents once again.
- Anne, thank you very much.
That was wonderful and that was terrific
and we're going to have
a lively discussion now.
I realize that in my introduction
I made at least two mistakes.
Number one was I forgot
to tell our audience
that they're supposed
to be asking questions.
So this is a webinar and if you all look
at the bottom of your screen
to the sort of center right
there's a thing called Q&A
where I believe if you
type in your question
I'll be able to see it
and then I'll be able as moderator
to pass it on to Anne Applebaum.
Oh my gosh, yeah,
the raising hand thing
isn't gonna work though.
So I see that some of you
are raising your hand.
It would be cool if instead
you would use the Q&A function
as one of you just did.
Okay, great, we're off to a good start.
My second mistake is
that I forgot to mention
that Anne is a Yale graduate,
but fortunately she rescued me
by mentioning it six
times during the talk.
- [Anne] Twice.
- Oh sorry, okay, twice.
She rescued me by mentioning
it during the talk.
That's all the more reason
we're happy to have you
as it were back,
and in the hope to have you back again.
I'm gonna buy a little time
as the questions accumulate,
and maybe Professor Stanley
will wanna do the same
and join us,
just by giving you a
couple of broad questions
to think about,
and you can just pick if any of these
strike you as interesting.
They have to do with themes
that have already begun
to emerge in the class
and which you've put a name on too.
I was in Kiev this weekend
and I was in Kiev to talk about
this strange sort of open letter
that Vladimir Putin wrote
about Ukraine and its history,
and this may seem very far apart
from what we're working on in this class
and it may be the influence
of this class on me
that I read it this way.
So Mr. Putin wrote this long letter,
as some of you will know,
basically making a historical case
that the Ukrainian nation doesn't exist
and concluding that as a result
it's up to Russia to decide
whether Ukraine is sovereign or not.
And as a I was reading this,
I mean, I read this and I was asked
to make a public critique of it
and that's why I was in Kiev
and I said a number of things,
but one thing which is on
my mind which I didn't say
was that when I read this
particular form of history,
that's the right word,
I was struck by how much it
reminded me of white supremacy.
That what Mr. Putin was
doing was basically saying,
he was telling other people
what their history was
and telling them that they
didn't really have a voice in it
and that he had the final
word in what had happened.
And in a very broad way
that's a way in which I think
just beginning to teach this class
has helped me to make connections,
'cause I wouldn't have thought of that
if it hadn't been for this class.
But if you read the letter,
and I'm gonna recommend to the students
that you do read this letter
because it's a striking example
of a history that's so one-sided
where one person doesn't
see any problem in saying,
"You were happy, everything
was fine, nothing was wrong."
But this leads me to a
theme which is in your book
and in your other work
but didn't come out so much in the lecture
so maybe I'll just ask you about it,
and that's the theme of
ethnicity and nationality.
It's very striking, as you know,
that at particular moments,
specially around collectivization
and then at the end of
the Second World War,
and also during the period
of political prisoners in the 1970s,
Ukrainians are vastly
overrepresented in the camps.
And so I'm wondering if you would,
and then you mentioned your friend Genia
who's Polish and whose parents
probably called her Genka,
and the Poles were also
vastly overrepresented.
They were a tiny minority
but they were vastly overrepresented
in the camps and in the shootings.
I wonder how at the end of your research
you think about this.
If it's an economic,
if it's on the surface economic
but then it's also about punishment,
why do we explain in this system
which is supposed to be
after all internationalist,
how do we explain that
certain kinds of people
end up being punished
in such obviously greater
numbers than others?
- Thanks, it's a great question
because one of the old
cliches about the Soviet Union
used to be that, well,
the Nazis killed people for racial reasons
and the Soviet Union killed
people for class reasons.
And one of the other impacts,
one of the other things you get
from reading Soviet archives,
which me and many other
people have done since 1990,
is the extent to which that's
not true becomes clear.
So what the Soviet Union did was,
what Stalin's Soviet Union did
was it identified potential enemies,
you know, who might be our opposition?
Who might be in opposition to the state?
And there were different qualities
that could make someone an enemy,
and one of the qualities was
if you were a former Russian aristocrat
or if you were a former
military officer and so on.
But another quality that
made you a potential enemy
was being from a potentially
enemy ethnic group.
And actually the so-called
Great Terror of 1937 and 1938
begins with, and again we know
this, this is now documented,
begins with the purge of Poles.
And so all over the Soviet Union
there's not millions and millions
but there are many Polish citizens
because of the way the borders
have moved over history,
because part of what was once Poland
later became Russia and so on,
there are a number of
ethnically Polish citizens
lives in the USSR in the 1930s, even then.
And there's a purge of them,
they're arrested en mass.
Anybody with a Polish surname
becomes liable for arrest.
And then a similar,
there's a similar effect
that affects Ukrainians
a little bit later on.
Ukraine is a little bit different.
It's bigger, there's
actually Ukrainian, you know,
a Ukrainian republic
within the Soviet Union.
But the Ukrainians,
as you know and as you've written about
and I've also written about,
are then targeted in a different way.
They're deprived of
food in the early 1930s
and deliberately left to starve
because that then eliminates
this problem of Ukraine,
that Stalin perceives Ukraine as a problem
because the Ukrainians
haven't entirely accepted
the Soviet ideology.
So what you see is that
ethnicity becomes one of the,
and it's not as if the
Poles were arrested in 1937
or the Ukrainians were murdered in 1933,
it's not as if anybody has really examined
whether these people
are pro or anti Soviet
or what their political views are.
They're targeted because
nationality and ethnicity
have become a kind of symbolic marker.
They're used as, ah, you were this,
therefore you're probably an enemy.
Your nationality is a kind
of identifying quality.
And when we are seeking
to eliminate all enemies
or we're seeking to cleanse the system
to make sure that only
our people are inside it,
one of the markers that's used is that.
And all through the Soviet Union
as you know there are different phases,
there are different moments
when different ethnic groups are targeted.
And actually at the end of Stalin's life
he began targeting Jews.
This is the same as
so-called doctors' plot
was beginning a widespread investigation
of Jews in the system
and many Jews were fired
and this actually even had an echo
in some of the satellite states,
in the Czech Republic.
Actually, it wasn't called
the Czech Republic then,
it was Czechoslovakia.
In Czechoslovakia there
was a purge of Jews as well
that was an echo of the Soviet version.
So, different ethnic
groups could be isolated
and picked on and eliminated
as a way of fulfilling this anxiety
the system had about itself.
I mean, I really do think
that Putin is anxious about Ukraine,
and I don't mean in a kind of
Freudian psychological way.
I mean he's anxious for a reason.
Because Ukraine poses a
challenge to Russia today,
and it's the same kind of
challenge Ukraine posed to Stalin.
Namely, it's a country that is
closely related ethnically to Russia,
yet it doesn't accept the
ruling ideology of Russia.
It wants to be different.
In modern Ukraine's case
it wants a more democratic,
less kleptocracic political system.
In the 1930s,
Ukraine wanted some of its own
national status and language.
And the reaction of the totalitarian,
of the autocrat, of the authoritarian
is to eliminate, as you say,
either eliminate the history
or eliminate the reality
of these opposing nations.
And it's a character trait that you can,
Putinism is not Stalinism,
they aren't the same thing at all,
but there are these echoes
from the past into the present
in which the,
anybody who's seen as
outside of our group,
anybody who offers an
alternative view of the world
has to be eliminated or denied agency
or removed of their history
because they're a threat
to the mainstream.
So in that sense
it's a really important theme
all the way through the Soviet Union,
not something that I think
was sufficiently understood.
We believe their language
about internationalism
and so on and class warfare,
and while the Soviet Union
existed it was much harder to see
exactly how racist it was.
- So, Jason, do you wanna come in?
We've got a bunch of
questions now, so we're good,
but if you wanna come in first, please do.
- Yeah, I'm just gonna say
that one of the questions
of our seminar is,
how do prison systems become massive?
What are the elements, the
core elements that result
in the kind of enormous
prison systems you see
say in the United States
now, in the Soviet Union,
and whether ethnicity,
targeting an ethnic group,
is necessary for that mass structure,
or at least always implicated.
- So, you certainly need an
element of dehumanization.
In other words, you have to,
in the Soviet Union it's not only ethnic.
It can be ethnic and it was often ethnic
but it wasn't only ethnic.
But you need to have identified
some group as less worthy,
or they aren't real citizens,
or they aren't the same as the rest of us,
or they are somehow deserving
of being locked up en mass,
they aren't part of the same,
they don't have the same status,
the same citizenship as us.
And that can be ethnic or
racial, and has often been,
but it's not only that.
So, as I said,
the moment of mass expansion
in the Soviet Union
is also this moment of collectivization.
For those who don't know,
that's the moment when
peasants were forced to
leave their private farms
and forced onto these collective farms,
and many resisted, they
didn't wanna do this,
they didn't wanna give up
their cow to the collective
and they were worried they would starve,
which, actually, they did.
They were right to worry.
And so there was a mass
arrest of peasants.
They were kulaks.
They were given a special
name, anybody who resisted.
It was supposed to be rich peasants
but actually anyone who
resisted collectivization
was named a kulak and they
were liable to arrest.
And alongside this campaign to arrest them
there was a massive propaganda effort
to dehumanize the kulaks.
The kulaks are preventing the revolution.
The kulaks are opposed to the rest of us.
There'd be caricatures of the evil kulak
with a long beard and sort of evil eyes
and scary-looking faces
that you would find in the Soviet press.
And they would be associated
with the White Guards
and the aristocrats
and whatever, Satan and
the devil, almost anything.
They were made into enemies.
And that was both,
and that allowed the
guards to accept the fact
that they were there
and it also allowed the
rest of the population
to accept these mass arrests.
So obviously, if you're
surrounded by evil people
who are seeking to overthrow the state
and ruin your revolution
and they're the ones who are preventing us
from achieving full
communism and, I don't know,
manna and honey and milk
and honey for everybody,
these are the people standing in the way,
of course you're willing to remove them.
And there's an echo of this, I mean,
I spent a little bit when I
was writing the Gulag book
and I did a little bit
similar in the Ukraine book,
I spent a lot of time
looking at how the guards
talked about the prisoners,
what's the way they spoke about them,
and I mentioned this in the speech
but I'll just emphasize it.
They are seen as lumps of coal.
They have no humanity.
When people are outraged
that they are staving,
it's not because there are hungry people
but because how do you expect us
to fulfill the production quotas
with these starving people?
They're too weak to work.
In other words, the system
successfully removes them.
They aren't citizens, they aren't like us,
they deserve to be in this prison.
And that can but doesn't
have to be ethnic or racial,
it can also be political.
You can politicize any group, in fact,
and make it into an enemy group.
You don't even need to have
ethnic and racial differences.
- Okay, if it's all
right I'm gonna go ahead
and just read some of
these thoughtful questions
that we have.
With the convention, by the way,
to all of you who are watching
is that I'm not gonna
give the names of people
who are asking the questions,
so I'm just gonna give the question.
So, a question is,
and I'm also gonna skip
the part where you say
how great a lecture it is.
I'm gonna skip that part,
I'm gonna go right to the question.
"I was really surprised,"
this is a question,
"I was really surprised
that more of Russian society
"doesn't talk about the Gulags
"given how extensively the
system had impacted the lives
"of many of the Stalin era.
"My question is about
public and social memory.
"I was curious about the differences
"between Russians who had
experiences with incarceration
"and those who did not.
"Could you tell us more about
your conversations with them,
"that is people who had been incarcerated.
"How did they remember
the Gulag differently?
"Did the perception and language
"of those who had been incarcerated
"challenge the wider amnesia or denial
"in wider Russian society
"or was there a similar
cognitive dissonance?"
- It's a trickier question to answer now
than it was really, frankly, 30 years ago,
25 years ago when I was
working on the book.
The generation of people who I interviewed
aren't there anymore,
and so this isn't a living question
in the same way that it
was a few decades ago
because most Gulag survivors
are no longer with us.
Enough time has passed.
I mean, it's a question
that's complicated by politics
because, as I said,
while the Gulag existed,
everybody knew about it.
It was a secret and not a secret,
a little bit in the way
that famine in Ukraine
was a secret but not a secret.
So you couldn't not know.
Everybody lived in communities
where there were prisoners.
If we're talking about arrest
of 10 or 15% of the population
then everybody has a cousin
or a friend or a relative,
everyone knew that
someone had been arrested.
So the lack of...
And it raises an interesting question
about what is knowledge and
when do people know things
and what do we mean by public memory,
because everyone knew
and yet it was not allowed to be discussed
or you weren't able to discuss it.
And so the way that conversations
about the Gulag worked
is that in very private little circles
people did talk about it.
And so there's a famous
circle that developed
around Eugenia Ginzburg
who was a famous Gulag survivor in Moscow
and she was a sort of proto dissident
really before there were dissidents,
and she gathered around herself
a lot of people who would
come and would talk about it,
and their friends and
relatives would know about it
and they were able to
speak about it freely,
and their children would know about it
and I've met some of their children,
and people in their
immediate circle would know.
And then there would be
other people in other circles
who would never speak about it again.
They would come home and never talk.
So actually the real
distinction wasn't between
people who were there and
people who weren't there.
The real distinction was between
people who because of the politics
and the culture of their
particular community
were able to speak about
it and those who weren't.
So in interviewing people you
got very different reactions.
I had one or two people I
interviewed in the 1990s
who were still really too
frightened to speak about it.
They very much didn't wanna say,
very clammed up, nervous talking to me.
"What are you gonna do with
this information if I tell you?
"Why do you have a tape recorder?"
So even then there were
people who were afraid
and then there were people
who you would ask them one question
and they would speak for hours.
In fact, sometimes that was a problem,
as anybody who's ever
done oral history knows.
You had to kind of get them back
onto the thing you really
needed them to speak about.
So the difference was,
the difference was that there
were pockets of the society
where it was okay to speak
about these things in private
and then there were other
pockets where it wasn't.
And why that was,
it could be to do with fear,
it could be to do with status,
the higher status you
were in the Soviet system
the less you were likely to
wanna discuss these things.
It could be to do with personalities.
So the memory of it really
depended on where you were
and something like that persists today.
So you can still go to Moscow
and you can meet people who
know a lot about Russian history
and will speak about it at great length.
There are some great Russian historians
who write in Russian.
It's not as if there's no
research done on this subject.
Actually, all the best
historians are Russians.
The really good ones.
I think you're reading Oleg Volkov.
The ones who really know
the most are Russians.
There are a couple of
Russian institutions,
there are a few publishing houses.
My Gulag book has been
published in Russia,
a very, very small, I think
500 copies or something,
but it was translated.
So there is a kind of community of people
who speaks about it,
it's not totally illegal.
But what there isn't,
it's not part of public
discussion or debate.
I'm guessing that depending on the teacher
it might occasionally appear
in a school curriculum.
But there isn't a memorial,
there isn't an annual celebration
like there is Holocaust Day
or Holodomor Day in Ukraine.
There isn't a...
It's not part of the national narrative.
Putin rewrote the national narrative
to focus not on the Gulag, not on Stalin,
not on the dissidence, not
on the human rights movement,
but on 1945 which was the year
of the greatest Soviet
domination of Europe
and the victory in the war.
And so every year now
there's an annual parade
that mimics this victory
parade that they had in 1945.
And so somehow this story
gets left out of the picture.
And so, again, it's not
illegal, it's not impossible,
it's just not present in public culture,
and public culture is very
heavily controlled by the state.
So there isn't a culture
of independent universities
who can argue with the public culture.
There are independent
magazines and newspapers
but they're increasingly
oppressed and marginalized,
quite a lot of them are
based outside of Russia now.
The journalists have difficulty
making themselves heard.
And actually there's a famous
case going on right now.
There is a Gulag historian,
he was a sort of amateur historian
and archeologist from Karelia
and who I actually met while
I was working on the book
and whose family I've been in touch with,
who's now under arrest.
And he's under arrest
on some false pretenses
to do with supposedly child pornography.
It's a completely trumped out fake case.
But the real reason he's under arrest
is because he's a public historian
who spoke about these issues
and was very much associated with them
and Petrozavodsk which is
the town that he comes from.
So you can be,
people who are too loud about these things
can get in trouble.
Some people continue in private
circles to speak about it.
But it's not part of what
Putin wants people to think of
when they think about
the history of Russia.
- So this question,
this epistemic question,
as you said, what it means to
actually know about something,
and how knowledge comes out
and how it might have a political effect
is something which is on the minds
of I think a number of the students.
You referred indirectly
to the chronicle of
current events in Russia
and the attempt by, you know,
Russians and Ukrainians and others
just to write down the simplest details
but abundant details of
what they could learn about-
- There's a lot about the
chronicle of current events
in the book.
- Yeah, yeah.
This is a theme which is gonna emerge
over the course of the class.
I have a question which is about it
so I'm gonna read it to you.
"You said that the Gulag
is rarely discussed today
"but that when it was
"the conversation delegitimized
the Soviet regime."
So now we're gonna move slowly
into some comparative questions
'cause this student is
wondering how this works.
"In the US we've had repeated
societal conversations
"about mass incarceration,
"specially in the last year.
"Do you think this public debate
"has deligitimized institutions
like prisons genuinely,
"or superficially, and if the latter,
"what's missing in the public dialogue?"
- That I don't know that
I'm competent to answer
because I haven't spent a lot of time
thinking about this question in the US.
But it's certainly true
that conversation about
mass incarceration has,
I mean, for example,
the criminal justice bill passed
during the Clinton presidency
which is now held to be
responsible for mass arrests
was for a long time by a
pretty wide range of people
thought to be a good piece of legislation.
It was something that Clinton himself
would have taken credit for at
the time that it was passed.
And quite a lot of people
actually black and white
it had a lot of support.
Retrospectively, it's
now heavily criticized
and it's now seen as the
source of these unfair arrests
or unfair prison sentences.
And even things like the,
and in a similar way laws on marihuana
I think are now retrospectively seen
as overtly harsh and ridiculously punitive
given that Americans drink so much anyway.
So one thing that conversation does
I wouldn't say that it's
delegitimized the political system
but it's certainly delegitimized
the assumptions that led to this process.
So do we really need these laws?
Was this the right way to do it?
Certainly, and maybe Jason
you can speak to this
more eloquently that I can,
certainly the conversation about
police reform, police brutality
has been bumped up I think and probably
also given energy by this question of,
are too many people in prison?
Have too many people been locked up?
So, the conversation,
having this be part of
the public conversation
does begin to affect the way
that people see the police,
the way people see the
criminal justice system,
the way people see these laws,
laws on, whatever, three
strikes and you're out,
the various laws that led
to larger and longer prison sentences.
So, yes, I think the public
conversation in that sense
did delegitimize that part of
the criminal justice system.
But not my area of expertise,
so I would like to hear
Jason talk about it.
- I mean, in fairness,
there are few people who
are capable of talking
about both of these
things at the same time,
and that's one of the reasons why
we're doing this exploratory course.
The point is not that Jason and I
know everything about both systems
and we're gonna lay it out there.
The point is that we have these two
really interesting phenomena
and we're gonna juxtapose and
we're gonna learn as we go-
- It's like comparing the
Holocaust and the Gulag.
They're not the same.
But it's interesting to talk
about them together, so.
- Yeah, some people
have even written books
where they're together.
- I don't know anyone, but
some people might have.
- There's probably somebody
out there somewhere.
So, I'm gonna,
there's an important
substantive question here
which going back to Russia
and then maybe we'll do
a little more comparison.
Was there continuity between
punishment or incarceration
in czarist Russia before 1917
through the development of
mass incarceration in Gulag
in the next decades?
And, and another student
asks this question as well,
was there continuity between the Gulag
and post-Soviet Russia?
- Right.
So the answer is kind
of yes and kind of yes.
The czarist system
was actually, retrospectively,
relatively mild.
If you look at the numbers
of political prisoners,
they're in the few
hundreds or few thousands.
I think at the beginning of the revolution
there were a few thousands
political prisoners,
which is by comparison to the millions
who were imprisoned by Stalin
is very very low.
And the system was very loose.
In fact, it was so famously loose
that Stalin escaped I think three times
from Russian places of exile,
which is sort of amusing
if you think about it.
And one of his, you know,
it was so easy to escape
from Russian prisons
that he decided that when
he was finally in charge
he was gonna make sure
that they weren't so easy
to escape from again.
So there were substantive
differences in scale,
but there were a few things,
so the idea of sending prisoners
to the Far North and the Far East,
this was a czarist idea.
The idea that prisoners
should somehow be used
to exploit these coal mines
or gold mines in the distant tundra,
this was also a czarist idea.
So the czars also had the idea
that you could use prisoners
for these things that were
very difficult to achieve
using normal people.
And so this was something
that the Bolsheviks picked up,
this was an element of continuity.
Also, the other element
of continuity was the idea
that you could send prisoners
to settle empty places.
That there was all this empty
space in the Soviet Union
and we need to somehow fill it
and nobody wants to go there
'cause there's too many
mosquitoes and too cold,
so we can send prisoners there to do it.
And that idea is continuous
all the way through.
And some of the places, I mean,
some of the places of exile
in the Russian czarist era
and the Soviet era are the same.
And so there is a kind of
continuity of thinking about this.
Stalin didn't make up the idea
that you could use prisoners
to dig coal in the Far North.
That was an older idea.
And then I would say that
there is a similarity
not of the prisons but of the systems
in that the lack of rule of law,
the fact that the ruler
could decide what the law was
and what the sentence
was at any given moment
and that that could change
depending on political circumstances,
this is continuous between czarist Russia
and Stalin's Russia.
So there's no independent court system,
there's no independent way of making law
or of overseeing prison sentences.
The czar suddenly decides
that this group of people,
in the case of the Decembrists uprising,
this group of people deserve
specially hard sentences,
and he could decide that
they would get them.
And that's a similarity
to the Soviet system,
and then that's an element of continuity
that you have today.
In the Soviet Union I would
say in the 90s and early 2000s
it was fair to say the
Gulag system had ended,
there wasn't a system of
political prisons in Russia.
There is now beginning to be that again.
There are beginning to be people
who are sentenced for
purely political crimes
and are put in,
they're put in, you know,
there are still prison camps,
and very often they're in the same place
as the Soviet camps.
I was once in a prison in
Arkhangelsk, of all places.
This is, again, this is about
early 2000s, I would say.
I was in the prison, it was
a modern Russian prison.
This was not a political prison,
these were just criminal prisoners.
And it was the same
building that had been used
during the Soviet period
and it was the same
building that had been used
during the czarist period.
So very often the places and
the buildings are the same,
and then of course that also
means that institutionally
the behavior of the guards, the customs,
how people are treated,
there's a kind of constant
institutional memory,
and that's true of the present.
If you read Mikhail Khodorkovsky
who was a Russian businessman
who was in prison for many years,
if you read his memoirs he talks about
being treated by guards in
ways that sound very familiar
to anybody who's read
the history of the Gulag.
So although the numbers aren't as great,
although they're building up again slowly,
the numbers of purely political prisoners
aren't as large.
The prisons themselves,
the systems by which
they're run and organized,
the language and nature of the guards,
the conditions are surprisingly,
there are surprising
similarities and echoes
up until the present.
So it's almost as if you
can change the politics
but you don't necessarily
change the jailers.
The jailers still, when
someone goes to work in a jail,
he's going to work for an older person
who used to work in the jail.
And if you haven't had a
major prison revolution,
or prison reform I mean, sorry,
which you have not had in Russia,
you did not have it after the 1990s,
then why would they change?
The system remains the system
as it was invented many years ago.
It has been altered, people
aren't starved to death anymore
and they aren't worked to death anymore,
but the system as it was in the 80s
and the system as it is now
aren't remarkably different,
which isn't surprising given
that the chain of people,
the chain of, you know,
the training and the
experience of the guards
is very similar.
- Can I ask a quick question, Tim?
So, we discussed Foucault's
"Discipline and Punish"
last week in class,
and Foucault has this
discussion of illegality
where he says it's important to create
this zone of illegality
so that revolute people who,
the class that might
rebel against the system
is thrown into prison as criminals.
They're delegitimized
as political prisoners.
So, one, when they do seek to rebel,
you say oh they're just common criminals.
That's obviously a theme
in the United States.
To what extent is that a theme-
- Huge, really important theme
both in Stalin's Russia
and in modern Russia.
In Stalin's Russia there were so many laws
and there were so many ways to break them
that it was very hard
not to break any laws.
But even in modern Russia
there's an excellent line,
there's a book by Chrystia Freeland
who's now a Canadian politician
but who used to be a journalist,
wrote a very good book about Russia,
it was about the
privatization era of the 90s,
and she had a line in
it where she talks about
Western advisors working in Russia
constantly advising
the Russians, they say,
"Well, you have all these
contradictory laws in which,
"you know, people doing
business in this, you know,
"are always breaking the law
because the laws are unclear."
And she said, "We kept pushing this.
"This is a big problem for you,
"why don't you fix this problem?"
And then suddenly it finally
dawns on them it's on purpose.
The laws are unclear for a reason.
Because everybody is a criminal.
So anybody can be arrested at any moment
if the state doesn't want them to be,
if they don't like their business
or they're not paying enough
money to the mafia boss
or whatever it is that they're doing,
they've always violated something
because the laws are badly written
and they seem to be written
that way on purpose.
And so, yes, absolutely,
the unclear laws, the badly written laws,
the creation of criminalizing.
In Stalin's Soviet Union there's a moment
where they criminalize,
the theft of grain becomes,
this is in a moment of heavy starvation,
becomes such a widely
defined category of behavior
that you could be arrested for picking it,
if somebody is carrying a bail of grain
and you pick up the leftovers
in put them in your pocket,
that can be a crime of
theft from the Soviet state
and you can go to prison for five years.
So all these systems have that phenomenon,
that many ordinary
activities are criminalized
or the laws are so badly written
that you're always bound to be
breaking one of them, so yes.
- Or the structures are such
that you have to break a law.
- You have to break a law in
order to do business in Russia.
You just can't do business
without breaking a law.
- Yeah, one interesting difference
between the US and Russia I think,
people can correct me,
is that in Russia
middle class people who are
running small businesses
are constantly afraid that
they're gonna be arrested
because they will be, it's
very likely that they will be.
- If someone doesn't like them
or wants their business, yeah.
- Yeah, and in the US,
at least if you're a white
middle class businessman,
this is not something
you're thinking about it.
The laws may be contradictory
but you're not particularly
worried about this.
So you can have the same set of friends
in Cincinnati as you
do in Perm or whatever
and they're gonna have
very different fears
about the police coming for them.
- Yeah, no, I would say,
in the US there are various recourses.
You can get lawyers.
But you're right,
the ordinary business people
just for doesn't their jobs
are not afraid of being arrested.
- Yeah, okay.
And so who is afraid of that arbitrariness
is obviously one of the
things we're thinking about.
You've been very generous,
I'm gonna give you two
questions together about the US
knowing that this is not what
you really wanna talk about
but also since you've kindly volunteered
to take part in the class
on mass incarceration
in the US and the Soviet Union
and then one more question about Russia
and then we'll thank you again.
So, it's a general question which is,
how have your studies of the Gulag
impacted your understanding of
mass incarceration in the US?
And then there's a more specific
social and economic
history question which is,
if we link labor control and race,
do you see common threads
between Gulag camps
and Southern US penitentiaries
that were specifically plantations?
Angola, Louisiana,
Parchman Farm, Mississippi,
and the Texas prison
plantation system, for example.
- So, the first question,
I don't know if my study
of the Gulag has impacted
my understanding of mass
incarceration in the US.
Certainly a study of the Gulag
and more broadly a study
of the Soviet Union
has impacted my understanding
of how propaganda is used, for example,
in the US and Europe
and really everywhere else in the world.
And it's made me hyper-allergic and aware
of certain kinds of tactics and
techniques that I, you know,
again, I don't wanna say
that Stalinism is the same
as anything we have in the modern world,
but there are themes.
I mean, it was while I was
writing my book about Ukraine,
about the Ukrainian famine,
I realized sort of,
Tim and Jason you've probably
had this experience as well,
you get to the end of the book
and you suddenly realize what it's about.
And this is what happened to me
when I wrote the Ukraine book.
I got to the end of the
book and I suddenly realized
it's about dehumanization and hate speech,
which wasn't how I started
out thinking about the book,
but of course why was it possible
to starve the Ukrainians?
It was because they were
publicly vilified in this way.
And so I would say that my
study of the Soviet Union
has helped me to think about
propaganda and how it's used
rather than given me specific insights
into the American prison system.
I would put it that way.
Gosh, is the US,
I mean, the use of forced labor...
There is a big argument in
the world of Gulag studies
as to whether the Gulag counts
as a slave system or not
or whether it's something different,
and that's often a kind
of semantic argument
about how are these things similar
and how are they different.
But I would say that the use
of forced labor and slavery
does have some common features.
Again, it has to be accompanied
by a sense of the people who
are doing the forced labor
aren't of the group as us.
They have some feature,
it can be political as it was in Russia,
it can be ethnic as it was in Russia,
or it can be racial as it
was in the United States.
They have to be somehow qualified
as not deserving of having free will
and the ability to choose
what kind of labor they do.
And so you can say that that was the same.
And the creation of special
categories of people
who don't deserve citizenship
and who don't deserve the
protection of the rule of law.
I mean, the enormous difference
is that there is protection
for the rule of law for some
people in the United States,
which there isn't in Russia at all.
And so it's not exactly
the same kind of problem.
But yeah I think you
can make that comparison
when you look at,
read carefully, this is in my book,
if you're reading part of the book,
if you read the chapiter on guards,
read the justifications that
the guards make to themselves.
Why is it okay to mistreat prisoners.
That's somewhere, I'm
afraid I can't tell you
which page or which chapter
number it is anymore.
How is it that the guards tell themselves,
what do they tell themselves
about the prisoners?
And then you might have an
interesting basis for comparison
to slave owners.
What are they telling themselves?
How are they justifying it to themselves?
That would be an interesting place
to look at what's the language being used.
- Okay, thank you, thank
you for stretching yourself
in our direction.
I'm now going to give you a softball
Soviet historiography question.
This is from another student.
If the reason for the Gulag
was fundamentally economic,
was the stated reason for imprisonment
being an enemy of the people
simply a cover for the
economic imperative?
- Actually, no, maybe I didn't
explain myself that well.
The stated reason was economic
and when they talked about themselves,
when the Stalin and the Yezhov
or whoever at the politburo
were talking among themselves
they spoke about the
Gulag in economic terms.
But that wasn't really its only reason.
It was also a form of terror.
And so it had these dual functions.
But I found the way they
spoke about it interesting
for the reason I just answered,
namely to justify it to themselves,
to explain what they were doing.
Remember, these are
people who say in public,
"We are internationalists,
"we believe in the
brotherhood of all peoples,
"we're building the perfect society,
"we believe in peace and brotherhood."
They had to explain why this state
which was extensively about
creating good for mankind,
why did it need to arrest
millions of people.
And the reason they gave to
themselves was often economic
when they spoke among themselves.
But that doesn't mean it was
the only function of the Gulag.
I mean, how did it
function in Soviet society?
And this you can get not
just in prisoners memoirs
but from other memoirs and
from literature as well.
It functioned in Soviet society
as a form of terror,
so people were afraid of it.
If I do something wrong,
I'll end up there.
If I step out of line, my
daughter will be arrested.
So it functioned as a thing
in the back of people's heads
that kept people in line,
so it actually had a number
of different functions.
And the reasons for arrest, I mean, again,
there's a famous, Anna
Akhmatova, a famous famous poet,
who used to say when
people would get arrested
or someone would be arrested
and people would try to justify it,
"Oh, well, so and so, we
knew he would be arrested
"because he said X or Y."
She would say, "Don't
you realize everyone,
"you're all arrested for nothing."
You could invent any reason
to arrest anybody, anybody.
And this is another related subject,
the danger of anonymized
irresponsible bureaucracies
is that people could use them.
So you were jealous of
your neighbor's apartment
and you wanted to get one
of those rooms for yourself,
that's how housing worked
in the Soviet Union,
you could denounce your neighbors and say,
"I heard them saying
something mean about Stalin."
People would denounce other people
because they were in love with their wives
and they wanted to...
So the arrest system was
also used and manipulated
by ordinary people
in order to take advantage of it.
So, why you were arrested?
There could be a reason for it,
you could belong to the wrong ethnic group
or be at the wrong
place at the wrong time,
or it could really be
pretty arbitrary and random.
- Okay.
We haven't gotten
through all the questions
but we've gotten through
most of the themes
of the questions.
You've been very patient with us
and we're grateful for that,
as well as for the accessible, articulate,
and extremely helpful for us
at the beginning of our class lecture.
So, Anne, thank you very
much for being with us.
Thank you very much for your work
and thank you for helping us make a start.
- Thanks to both of you
and thanks to the students.
It sounds like a fascinating class
and I'm just sorry I can't take it.